danièle obono député la france insoumise
de la dix septième circonscription de
paris en direct par téléphone vont soir
danielle obono tout en vert donc excepté
mayotte guyane et l'ile-de-france
edouard philippe qui salue l'attitude
des français des soignants une fois
n'est pas coutume avez vous envie de
saluer la stratégie du gouvernement ce
soir écoutez la stratégie on va voir
comment elles se déploient dans ces deux
thèmes fall pour le moment qui est sûre
on va être d'accord avec le premier
ministre sur le fait que c'est
effectivement grâce à l'implication des
soignants leur engagement sans faille et
bien sûr la mobilisation de la
population qui a assuré la réussite du
confinement que cette deuxième phase est
possible et donc il voulait on
s'accordera sur ce constat portier de la
stratégie du gouvernement il ya encore
beaucoup de questionnements sur les
moyens qui sont mis en oeuvre on fait
que par exemple sur la question des
écoles dans l'île de france par exemple
moins de deux élèves sur dix ont repris
l'école parce que les moyens pour
garantir la sécurité sanitaire ne sont
pas réunies dans une majorité
d'établissements scolaires et c'est le
résultat du manque de planification du
manque de concertation avec les
personnels de l'éducation nationale qui
n'ont pas du tout été impliqué dans la
réflexion sur cette réouverture des
écoles et je crois que la deuxième phase
avec la relance économique doit être
aussi planifié de cette manière là c'est
à dire avec bouscule sion dans les
secteurs sur la manière dont les
garanties sanitaires les professions
sanitaires ce n'était quand même pas la
priorité puisse être assurée à la fois
dans les commerces pour les salariés
elle est ouverte puisque ton ceux qui
vont sont faites des taux qui vont être
aussi qu'ils vont reprendre du travail
sur ti et donc il faut que leur sécurité
soit garantie sur celle des usagers
et des clients et donc on va voir
comment il claque des bois mais
permettait quand même que l'on rappelle
les erreurs les retards et le manque ni
compris jusqu'à présent d'un certain
nombre d'éléments comme cruciaux que ce
soit la question des têtes ou des mac
pour que nous restions en tout cas
extrêmement vigilant et lille nantes
quand on ne croit la population les
jusqu'à présent et qui a permis cette
deuxième phase en tout cas effectivement
ce déconfinement le sens s'accélère à la
faveur de bons chiffres même si on nous
le rappelle tout le temps et évidemment
il faut rester prudents et bars et
restaurants qui rouvre totalement en
zone verte uniquement les terrasses en
zone orange dont l'ile-de-france ça vous
inspire quoi c'est un petit peu la
double peine peut-être un pour les
restaurateurs d'ile-de-france qui ont
déjà suivi la crise et gilet jaune qui
subissent maintenant voilà cette
discrimination peut être obligatoire
mais discrimination quand même tout le
monde n'a pas une terrasse
quelle est votre réaction écoutez c'est
une situation extrêmement difficile
effectivement pour énormément de
commerce de travailleurs avaient
indépendant de professions libérales et
bien sûr qu'il faut que l'état joue tout
son rôle de protection économique
il y a eu des fonds qui ont été mis en
oeuvre pour indemniser la fin des
relations il faut que ces fonds soient
prolongées et que pour sur l'ensemble du
territoire mais en particulier dans
l'est dans les territoires qu'ils vont
avoir un déconfinement économique plus
progressif et plus lents il faut assurer
effectivement l'indemnisation de tous
les commerces qui ne pourront pas ouvrir
ou pour qui l'ouverture mais ces titres
à un investissement important et c'est
là où le rôle de la puissance publique
et est primordiale et je crois que que
ce soit sur la libéralisation de la
perte d'exploitation que ce soit sur le
chômage partiel qui doit être assurée
jusqu'au bout et au plus haut plus haut
niveau possible
et puis plus largement je crois que
l'enjeu
si on parle de relance économique il
faut quelqu'un crie en fait dans une
véritable trappe et y est on est dans un
moment où toutes les mesures qu'on met
en sommes aujourd'hui y compris au
niveau économique ont déterminé la suite
monde est terminée la direction vers
laquelle on va s'orienter pour la suite
et pour la relance économique
oui pour les commerces pour ses
activités là il faut que l'état joue un
rôle de stratège et puis permet cette
relance là dans le sens de ce que nous
on croit est nécessaire que la mouture
wallon écolo
oui il est dans ce secteur-là il ya
énormément d'emplois qui peuvent être
créées qui doivent être créés et qui
vont soutenir y compris la demande qui
permettra aux commerces de rattraper en
fait les les pères petits qui sont
importantes effectivement un autre mois
dagnogo nothin on va pas réussi à vous
poser la troisième question et doit
finir dans son ensemble appel à la
responsabilité on ne peut pas courir le
risque de la désinvolture les
rassemblements d'une dix personnes sont
proscrits dans les endroits publics on a
vu ces derniers jours les a largement
commander des matchs sauvage de football
à strasbourg dans l'essonne quel est
notre réaction que faut-il comment
faut-il traiter justement ces personnes
qui enfreignent d'une certaine manière
les interdictions je suis à rappeler
quand même un peu sylvia des personnes
qui ont fait preuve de désinvolture
c'est d'abord le gouvernement en premier
lieu au début de cet été des niches et y
compris je les dis au début mais
rappelons que si nous avons pu arriver à
une situation où le niveau de
circulation du virus a été
considérablement réduite est parti une
mobilisation de la population qui a
respecté dans son camion intégralité le
confinement et quand ce n'était pas dans
un spectre c'était pour un certain
nombre de raisons y compris pour les
pour les personnels et les salariés qui
devait être sur site etc raoult qui
étaient obligés d'y être donc
franchement je ne crois pas que ce soit
la mettre la meilleure manière de de
poser
la question rappelons que le confinement
et la restriction des libertés parce
qu'on est quand même encore dans un état
d'urgence sanitaire qui donne des
pouvoirs exorbitants à l'exécutif qui a
donné les coups avis compris de ses
manquements et des abus qui peuvent
avoir lieu dans ce genre de cas et qui
restera énormément les droits et des
libertés
de quoi que les en fait les français
toute la population ont fait preuve de
civisme offre beaucoup plus que le
gouvernement y compris temps d'avoir les
moyens toujours de ta protection
je vous rappelle que les mac quand il
tendit gator ne sont pas
systématiquement gratuit que ce que tu
as beau être le cas et je crois en moi
que la population saura faire y compris
mieux que le gouvernement pour assurer
la protection des dents et des lunes et
des autres mais encore une fois le
gouvernement doit assurer les moyens de
cette protection
que ce soit au niveau humanitaire mais
également sociales et économiques merci
danièle obono d'avoir été avec nous pour
réagir à ces annonces d'edouard philippe
up